del 20 solita stories
oggi proviamo dei movie giochi g paura
proviamo innanzitutto come primo gioco
granny zombie che potete vedere del brut
e noi proveremo altri giochi mi
raccomando berat e video fino alla fine
perché poi nei commenti ci potrete dire
qual è stato il vostro gioco preferito
tra questi giochi che abbiamo provato se
questo video raggiunge i 20 mila vi
piace proveremo altri giofil
consigliateci pure che altri giochi
volete che proviamo a gesù ne comprende
sei pop corn mettetevi comodi e iniziavo
questo gameplay molto paura allora
difficoltà
mettiamo normale se nightmare nightmare
vuol dire incubo in inglese non giocare
se gli incubi ok prima proviamo normale
e poi proviamo dalità nightmare giorno 1
c'è qualcosa di verde malissimo del
verbo per caso mi dice che non sarò
molto brava qua allora la casa sembra
tipo la casa di shrek forte se le belle
e brutte che ho fatto di slime è verde
trasparente l aiuto di fatto spaventa
preso ok giorno 2 che proviamo
altrimenti proverò a vitale ma sto per
caricare file e tutte 500 26 che sta
aumentando già è dimagrita
ma cosa più brutta che allora questa
volta andiamo molto cauti
il primo era al piano di sole si farà mi
ricordo cosa devo fare prima devo aprire
queste porte devi trovare tutti gli
oggetti non per poter scappare ma non mi
dicono in che stanze erano 30 che se fai
rumore con la lampada si accorge aiuto
ma vi potrà nascondere da qualche parte
ma con distanza g g zombie delle
decorazioni un po particolari dicevamo è
questo una televisione e youtube casa è
passato a questa è la porta che ti porta
la porta il passaggio che ti porta al
piano di sopra dove c'è il ragno dei
ricordi ma vediamo magari invece di un
ragno ha messo uno slide a non è però
ancora più sommi siren attenta che lì
c'è il buco calder ma che devi fare così
quali ricordi tuccio quindi lì ti puoi
nascondere allora puoi entrare in questa
porta gialla per poter entrare bisogna
quindi poi non posso farglieli puoi
cadere nel caso giallo
vabbè prendiamo le scale piano sto per
la lampada è volato la cosa che governi
e proprio lingua non trovo nessuno
ma che paura che giornata è anche meno
camminate niente non avrà un oggetto
raccoglitore forse meglio se tu fai con
quello pratica perché sono grandi tv ok
giorno 4 che è tutto ok
buongiorno 4 padre che lo caso sentito
si reggina sta credendo che sia la voce
di grendi ma noi siamo bloccati qui
ancora inquietante così niente siamo
rimasti intrappolati dentro lo stato
bloccato un cervello e niente credi dire
che avevo perso passiamo al prossimo è
già ora di un voto da 1 a 10 al primo
gioco io gli do un sette e mezzo io e
voi che voto date scrivete nei commenti
ok secondo il gioco questo gioco si
chiama eyes adventure è praticamente
granny si trasforma in road di ice cream
o forse il contrario non ho capito bene
comunque vediamo un po come ok allora
difficoltà facile per ora proviamo gusti
e vediamo un po sarà pronto o fare
stiamo svegliando numeri è che siamo di
nuovo nella stanza di grandi zombie sì
però con i colori un pochettino di smith
e christmas un natale
allora per altro c'è scritto cinque
giorni ma cosa c'entra e sceneggiate
no no questo c'entra road ice cream
forse road è andato a trovare granny e
quindi è rimasto lì grandi sarà uscita è
rimasto solo rob.mar ad parla con la
voce che chiede perché non si nasconde
oddio guardate ekren divertito loro c'è
anche incastrata
[Musica]
e rimasta bloccata li sta visionando
come si chiude questa porta che all in
one sempre lettera l'armadio
si è rimasto pure fuori dall'armadio
rientrati giorno due premi protagonismi
perché c'è scritto pro a natale nelle
pareti con le creme terreni
forse un mix tra treni babbo natale e
milioni road ma perché se ne accorge
così in fretta questa la modalità facile
ma è tutto rosa invece a questa credo
che siamo saliti prima guarda forse con
questi colori è più bello rispetto a
quello che abbiamo visto prima che mi
sono nascosta qua dentro
ovviamente loro che mi sono una cosa non
arriva è nostro al piano di sotto
giustamente ci sarò io ti consiglio di
andare in quella porticina lì si in quel
mese fa il rumore lui chiesa non ha
fatto attraverso la porta da 1 a 3 ok
ora agiata evitare parco che mai visto
che la cava meglio di me
la trappola maledetto adesso non mi
ricordo come si fa a fare la trappola
che pensa più che da ronald no no non mi
sono bloccato
credo cioè sì non c'è il pulsante per
sbloccarmi signor g
arrivando alla stata un'altra trappola
ma qualche brutta risalita da rode
pelata dire che sono rimasto bloccato
perché mantenga pulsante
separarsi no giorno 4 non riuscivo mai a
scopa
red cro n questo è bello di questi
giochi è proprio quello che sono
impossibili da finire questa volta starò
più attento dei dm
secondo voi morirete ma queste pancia
vita si è riuscito almeno a trovare un
oggetto sentito rumore qua vicino
scary santa ma che c'entra se un po di
tuta dentro schieri santa schieri road
per olio nei colori più carini un
pochino più luminoso eccolo guarda che
devo dire non mi far arrabbiare che devo
dire
tutto bene per cercando di camminata
lenta
ok allora scendiamo giù in garage in
prova molto vicino comunque questo blu
rilassante
andiamo a vedere la macchina cerchiamo
di non fare rumore
sei anche la modalità facile lops ho
fatto vedere qualche cosa wow grimi si
tratta bene devo dire la sua macchina
ferrari cos'era
oddio che paura forse sono stato io ho
fatto vedere due volti della macchina
pensavo fosse un urlo non ho fatto
apposta tigre miei scritti posso
prendermi abbiamo visto il bar meno il
caso abbiamo visto ultimo giorno vediamo
un forum in dal menu l'ultimo giorno
vitale riuscirà a fare qualcosa tenutasi
chicca per evitare sono tagliati
benissimo bagno e meglio di quello di
grandi originale ovvero la geniale non
aveva la vasca da bagno dorata sai che
non mi ricordo in pericolo e
cristallizzata
ma cosa centra public il il quadro
immagino che aveva portato giù in garage
[Musica]
vediamo come finisce ci ha buttato giù
forse ci sarà il bonus
credo che il modo spedito
ok terzo e ultimo gioco queste super
strano perché in pratica è un mais pong
fondo è un misto di tre personaggi g
baldi a sportal.it chiama sporge brehme
non so perché ma la passa di spongebob e
ha più inquietante di tutt'e quattro
tutti i gremi strani che abbiamo trovato
secondo me questo è il più inquietante
con sono d'accordo abbiamo dato il voto
da 1 a 10 al secondo
allora secondo me era meglio del primo
poco meglio del primo era soprattutto
per i colori che non ti facevano male
agli occhi quindi la vita sei mesi e
mezzo a voi scrivete nei commenti il
vostro voto ma ora andiamo da bree
sponge premi vuoi mettere la difficoltà
più dai facile anche se è normale non
era molto facile all'altra vediamo un po
come questo
bobo horror per lui vediamo i colori
della casa sarà tutto giallo no
cominciamo subito con l'utilizzo lorizio
marrone al legno color legno youtube che
ci parla giorgio bomber cosa si è
scritto qua io penny wise il clown
ballerino noi ci conosciamo
no cosa la cosa centra spendi wise il
pagliaccio ok rom con il nome di chi ha
creato questo gioco e poi questo è il
joker
e la gioconda c'è un po di tutto si è
fermato lì
piano piano adesso è visto con pantaloni
e alla sponge polvere piano doveva mali
è domandato quindicenne dove stati
ridisceso religiosi luce che ben de
corato e di wise
ma cosa centra qua c'è un altro ma che
ha portato un po di colore è lo stesso
di prima
as è uguale martino avanti browser c'è
chi ha mai visto c'era anche il granchio
giorno 2 ripropone poi programmazione
che è veramente inquietante grendi
spongebob
ok giorno 2 mettiamoci intorno cosa
sbaglia un'altra porta che gli umori
sembrava plus terina dei colori molto
arcobaleno per questo bagno
il pagliaccio si no ancora cosa c'entri
forse lo troveremo le cose senza che due
temi l'accordo dove ti risponde c'è il
cielo armato e qui la manor madio corri
corri corri corri tutti ho preso di
sorpresa stato sorpreso maledetto breve
ma poi baldi cosa centra prendi in spose
brandi 3 ora probabilità le scappa
scappa scappa aiuto che paura per red
scommetti che questo è venuto qua già di
nascondersi sotto il letto
potrebbe essere una buona idea del tempo
r4 visto che non riusciremo ad andare
molto lontano sembrano davvero più
difficile questi giorni perché tutto
bianco che succede anche anche altro
gioco si era formato il giorno 4
siamo andate in paradiso forse brennus
pong brevità rinchiuso da qualche parte
con le luci accese
niente 7 perché ciò che noi non potevamo
ma ci ha colpito cioè modalità extra
difficile non vedo niente ma devi
scappare
già vediamo se riusciamo a vedere questa
volta in bianco grigio farvi il colore
con mano e devo dire che funzionano
benissimo però i giochi congressi
purtroppo anche il resto si è bloccato
al corto giorno dai pro vasto appare io
senza vedere niente
[Musica]
premiamo l'avana video dopo quanto tempo
mi troverà sposi brenni ci ha provato
bene questo responso brehme secondo me
il più inquietante quelli che voto diamo
questo ultimo non funzionava bene qui vi
do qualche punto solo perché era
inquietante di sono 65 voi che voto gli
date scrivetelo nei commenti e se non mi
seguite su instagram ancora andate a
seguirmi il nome anita stories
mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace e
votate il vostro gioco preferito qua
sopra o 4 prato e scriveteci quelli
altri giochi volete che proviamo ora vi
lasciamo a quattro casse linee su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite